[MUSIC PLAYING]
MUBINE DIN: Hi, everybody.
How are you doing?
Thank you for coming
along to our talk
on using AI to transform
fleet operations.
My name's Mubine Din, and I
work in Hitachi Consulting
within the Strategy
and Innovation Team.
ANDY LAMONT: Hi.
I'm Andy Lamont.
I work in our Digital
Transformation Practice
in the UK.
MUBINE DIN: So today,
we're here to talk to you
about Hitachi's
Predictive Maintenance
Platform for Fleet Operations.
Just to give you a bit of an
overview of how this session is
going to be
structured, it's going
to be similar to everywhere
you've been already.
We're going to
essentially tell you
why we've done what we've done
over the past three or four
months, so giving you some
information around the industry
issues we're trying to tackle
from a Fleet Management
perspective.
We're going to spend
some time showing you
how we've done what
we've done by taking you
through the architecture,
taking you through some
of those challenges and
design decisions we've made,
and then we're
going to show you--
because I think that's the
most important part, right?
You want to see what
we've done, and we'll
give you a demonstration
of how we've
applied this with one
of our clients as well.
The key thing I think all of
you are probably wondering
is, why do we have Lego?
So let's address that
elephant in the room.
You've probably walked
around the conference rooms
and seen the Lego
at the booth, and I
think more people have
been fascinated by the Lego
than anything else.
Essentially it's
a whole lot easier
to bring one of
those from the UK
than bringing an actual
vehicle, so we've
got this to support
one of our use cases
around AR guided
inspections, and we'll
give you a lot more
information about that
as we go through this session.
If we could hold all questions
until the end as well,
we'll allocate
some time for that.
But if we don't get around to
you because we run out of time,
please swing by the booth.
Ask for Meredith.
She'll be able to help
you out there as well.
Thank you.
Perfect.
I think we've talked about
this, but essentially our aims
are to show you what we've
done, explain why we've done it,
but also show you
where we're going next.
And just to give you all a
bit of context and information
about Hitachi, so
you've all probably
heard of us because we touch
pretty much all industries
from an industrials perspective
to a technology perspective.
We are a global
technology leader
founded over 100 years ago and
a global industrial powerhouse
with long term stability
and deep resources.
Hitachi has deep experience
in the industrials
and manufacturing space and
especially within the vehicles
and fleet management space.
So there's some interesting
information out there.
I won't talk about all of
it, but over 70% of vehicles
have at least one
Hitachi component,
and Hitachi
manufactures components
that amount to up to 45% of the
component building materials
you will have in a vehicle.
So we have deep, deep
experience in the manufacturing
space there.
But we also as
Hitachi have a lot
of experience in the ownership
and operation of large fleet
operations as well, so that
spanning from the automotive
to the trucking to
the heavy assets,
so your earth moving
materials as well.
And along those
lines, Hitachi's also
got deep experience
around IoT AI,
and we're bringing together
those with our use of Google
as our platform for bringing
our industrial experience
and heritage to the
industry to help
our clients within the industry
innovate and move forward.
We also are a combination of
800 plus subsidiary companies,
and that's how you've
probably seen a lot of Hitachi
touching your world.
So what are we here for today?
So today, we're here to
talk about fleet management
and how predictive maintenance
can support fleet management
activities, fleet optimization
activities specifically.
Fleet management
solutions need to evolve.
They need to move
from where they are.
Currently, Fleet
Management solutions
are often reactive
visualizations
of the information that you
have available to yourselves.
Reactive in terms
of maintenance,
but also reactive in terms
of any kind of optimization
activities as well.
Today, fleet
organizations essentially
have to compete with a
number of disrupting factors
such as startups, other entrants
into the market, rising fuel
prices, and complex
emission base regulations.
That's forcing them to
focus on efficiencies.
And within that,
maintenance costs for fleets
account for 15% to 20% of
your fleet's total costs,
so a prime area for optimization
and a prime area for AI and IoT
based solutions to
help reduce that cost.
Digital technologies are
changing most industries
in all areas, and
this is somewhere
where there's a
great opportunity
to provide efficiencies
and cost savings.
Just to give you all a bit
of contextual background
information, there are a
number of fleet maintenance
optimization challenges
that need to be addressed.
So Fleet Managers often lack the
pertinent asset condition data.
They may have data, but
a lot of the data that
gets collected across
fleets is captured
by individuals as
opposed to necessarily
being streamed back from
the vehicles themselves
in all instances.
There's excessive operational
maintenance costs,
so a majority of organizations
from a maintenance perspective
do periodic or cyclical
maintenance, where essentially
you are maintaining the
asset on a time based process
to essentially reduce
the risk associated
with that asset failing
at any point in time.
That's due to a lack of
available asset condition data
and a limited understanding
of the relationships
between the asset failure
events and the data
that you can get from
those assets beforehand.
Assets are becoming a whole
lot more complex as well,
so fleet operators
are having to manage
at larger scales with
more complex assets,
and that brings with it
its own nightmares as well.
And there's also the
challenge around knowing
when to maintain your assets
and when to replace your assets.
So for example, end
of life for assets
is calculated by organizations
usually on a time basis.
We can bring additional
data in to help
those types of organizations
retire those assets
and replace those assets
when they need to not just
because a certain
time has elapsed.
So this is a maturing process.
The move to
predictive maintenance
doesn't happen overnight.
We're on this trend
moving from data
reporting through to
descriptive analytics
and dashboarding to help
people understand their assets,
and through their use of
data and bringing in data,
you're able to move to
the predictive world
before we get to the
prescriptive world
where you're doing things
because you feel they're
going to fail or
you're doing things
before you need to do it.
Moving to Predictive Maintenance
is expected to save 10% to 20%
over preventative
maintenance practices,
and we'll break that
down a little bit as we
talk through this conversation.
And why now?
The big question is, has this
not been possible previously?
Why are we able to do
this at this point?
Technology convergence
is a key reason
we're able to essentially bring
a number of different data sets
together from both Edge devices
within vehicles, within assets,
as well as streaming data
from other data sources.
So we're talking
about the map, we're
talking about condition
data and all those pieces,
enabled by cloud computing
and big data tool kits.
So they really allow us to
stream and store vast amount
of data efficiently,
economically, and securely
providing monitoring
capabilities and the ability
to make interventions
before issues occur.
AI machine learnings
can be trained
against these large data set
at comparatively low cost
compared to in the past,
and advanced visualizations
through the use of
augmented reality
and also automated
dashboarding and those elements
can help surface the information
to the right individuals
at the right time so that they
can make those interventions as
needed.
And the big question
we have to ask
is, well, why do
you do these things?
Why do you go through the pain
of understanding and working
through those data elements?
And it's all about delivering
value for the organizations.
So fleet operations
are essentially
anticipated to reduce
costs by moving
to predictive maintenance.
Improve efficiency, so I'll
give you a few examples.
If we look at maintenance
as it stands at the moment,
we talked about it being
done on a cyclical basis.
If you maintain
assets when they need
to be maintained as opposed
to for the sake of it,
you reduce the downtime
for those assets.
So for example, you don't need
to take vehicles out of service
to go and do maintenance
against those assets.
You therefore make
those assets available,
and you can improve
your revenues
against those at that point.
You're reducing your
operational costs.
You're not having individuals
having to go and service assets
that do not need to be done.
And you also are able
to manage your Capex
and essentially focus and
work on those assets that
need the work when
they need the work.
So I've given you
a bit of context
and a bit of information around
why fleet organizations need
to consider predictive
maintenance,
need to understand
their assets better.
And that's understood,
and that's a key driver
across the industry.
However, there are
technological challenges
associated with this in terms
of streaming back fleet data.
So a lot of the data that
you pull off the vehicles,
for example, are unstructured,
or the data sources that
are available come through
as time series data
with varying
structures and schemas.
IoT data itself isn't going
to help you generate insight.
Insight comes together
from a combination
of additional
contextual data sources,
so knowing the actual
events that were occurring
at that point in time--
climate, temperature,
terrain, where
you were with that vehicle.
And also within the
work we've done,
we've identified that
you need SME input,
you need the knowledge and
information from those SMEs
that are working in
that space to help you
focus on the right use cases.
You can bring back
data from many sources,
but unless it's actually
serving a purpose
and working for the use case to
help the organization deliver
value, it's not going
to be worthwhile.
So I'll give you a bit
of an overview here
around what we have created
and why we have created it.
So essentially, Hitachi
has used GCP technologies
to deliver a Predictive
Maintenance Fleet Operations
Solution which overcome some of
the challenges I talked about.
We do two things
predominantly, and we'll
go into a lot of detail around
this from an actual feature
perspective and
functionality perspective.
But just as a high level
overview at this point,
we have created data dashboards
for maintenance planners that
look at the data that we pull
out of those vehicles compared
to contextual data sources,
and they look at the fault
information that
we've already created
and the AI models
we have created
to predict fault events.
And they surface the
right recommendations
to that maintenance planner
at the right time so they know
where and when they
need to maintain assets
comparing that against the
alerts that are also coming
back from the vehicle,
so it can be dynamically
updated throughout
their planning process,
but also looking at the
normal maintenance schedules
as well for those assets that
are not quite ready for this.
What we've also done is
working with our client
around the maintenance and
inspection space as well.
We've helped them
identify where they
need to work on their assets,
and we're using an AR guided
inspection application to help
their largely mobile workforce
understand the steps
they need to take
to complete that inspection
against that vehicle.
So our client has a
large mobile workforce,
but they also have a large
number of contractors
that they use as well.
And the AR guarded
application has
been super useful to helping
those contractor workforce
individuals understand
what they need to do
and where they need to do it.
We'll give you a
demonstration of that as well.
So that is using the AR
components of Android
but also using
Google Glass as well.
So in terms of giving you the
overview of what we've done
and how we've done it, I've
touched on the concept.
So our solution looks
at the end to end
using GCP all the way from data
ingestion from either the OBD
terminal that we have in the
vehicle or additional sensors
that we instill in
that vehicle, and Andy
will take us through in a little
while the Google GCP components
we use from an
architecture perspective
and why we use those.
We bring through the
data and both stream
it back depending
on the use case.
It's all around what we need
to show when we need to show it
and then using Google's
capabilities from an AI
perspective, using
AutoML, ML, we essentially
are doing the analysis
against that data set
to identify those
fault events, and we're
visualizing all of
that information
through assisted reality
and data dashboards
using Google Data Studio and
also the mobile and Glass
applications I talked about.
Just to give you an
understanding of why we're
doing what we're doing and how
we got to where we are today,
within Europe, Hitachi
own and operate
a number of rail trains.
And we provide those
trains to organizations,
but also they do the maintenance
services against those vehicles
as well.
As Hitachi were
creating those trains,
they were looking at what data
we would need to pull back
from these vehicles
and structuring
the development
of those and also
the development of the
data capture elements
on those trains to bring
back that information
so we could do things like
asset monitoring and asset
optimization.
That has evolved as we have
moved onto the GCP suite.
It's where we're looking
now with our fleet clients,
which we'll show the demo
for, to do Predictive
Maintenance using GCP.
So bringing in all of
that information is great
and visualizing it
is great, but we
are taking that next
step forward, bringing
in contextual data
sources and identifying
those types of failure events
that require intervention.
So the big question is, why AI?
Why now?
And the move from
descriptive analytics
to predictive
analytics is driven
by a maturity in AI technology.
So this won't be new to
a lot of you in the room,
but as businesses are
evolving faster than ever,
data has to keep up and
deliver the insights
for those individuals
within the organizations
and bring that data
to the front lines
to help them make the decisions
as and when they are needed.
And capitalizing
on data is not new.
People have been doing
it throughout time.
The difference now is that
this evolution of compute
and this evolution of scale
and speed and diversity
and the types of models
that are available
and the type of big
data technologies
that are available through
Google Cloud from a capture all
the way through storage,
processing and insights
perspective are pretty much
ready at this point in time
to help deliver those insights.
It's not about
big or small data.
It doesn't matter how
small the data set is.
It's about how you leverage
it with the insight
from the industry for
the right use cases
to deliver value to those
individuals as well.
And this is all about the move
from understanding or hindsight
through to insight.
So how do you get
insight available
within your organization to
know where you need to work?
And the overall,
overarching aim is
getting to foresight where you
are able to go and do things
before they occur.
We've all seen
Minority Report, right?
And just to touch on this
as we're talking through it.
Hitachi has deep experience
within the Maintenance world.
within the IoT world as well.
So we are able to leverage
not just the AI components
of Google, we're also able
to leverage the experience
that Hitachi has across
the Maintenance space
from a descriptive analytics
space to predictive and also
some of the newer things around
prescriptive analytics as well.
So for example,
Hitachi has AI solution
cause that we were able
to containerize and bring
into the Google
environment to do
certain things such as
operations risk or driver
behavior.
And we've used some
of that insight
not necessarily to
detect those faults
but to support that
data set that we're
using for the breaks
example, which I'll take you
through later today.
And also, there's
really important things
there around remaining useful
life estimation and fault
predictions around
other use cases
that we haven't necessarily
touched on in this space.
But the purpose of me showing
this and explaining this
is to say, we have great
experience in this space,
and we're able to bring those
with whatever use cases people
are looking to work on as well.
And all of this is in the
pursuit of total operation
optimization and automation.
So it's about moving from the
hindsight world to insight
and also to the
optimization space
where AI is not only helping you
understand what you need to do
but orchestrating or
running that for you
as an end to end system.
We're not quite
there, but that's
where everybody should be
walking towards as well.
So I'll stop there
for one second.
Just do a quick time
check with Andy.
How are we doing?
ANDY LAMONT: OK, fine.
Yeah, carry on.
MUBINE DIN: I'll
let you know that I
get told that I
like to talk a lot,
so I just have to use
Andy to keep me honest.
ANDY LAMONT: I'm here to throw
him off the stage in a moment.
MUBINE DIN: Perfect.
So before we actually get
in and start showing you
a bit about the
architecture, I'll
describe some of the features
of what we've been doing.
And when we do the demo, I'll
explain some of those pieces
as well.
So our Fleet Operations platform
does the normal condition
monitoring elements, so
you bring through the data
and you show some of the basic
elements like miles driven,
where the assets are,
and those elements.
We also do advance
failure prediction,
so we have two use cases
we're talking about today.
One around failure for air
conditioning units on fleet
vehicles, and one around failure
prediction for the brake pad
or brake elements of
the vehicles as well.
We also have anomaly
detection models
where we look at peak
performance versus norm
performance.
We bring in the intelligent
driver score elements
that we talked about.
And we surface all of
this to our end user
being the Maintenance Planner
through prioritized maintenance
dashboards where we
offset the real time
predictive recommendations
against some
of the cyclical work that's
been going on as well.
And we also surface
that information
through mobile and
Glass applications
to the engineers who are out
there doing the inspections
and completing that work.
I now hand over to Andy.
Thank you very much.
He'll give you an overview
of some of the architecture
components about what
we've been working on.
ANDY LAMONT: Hi.
So yeah, we've obviously
talked about the fact
that the end to end
capability, we're
looking to use GCP for this.
We've built a platform with
a number of the components.
So again, I'll maybe just
give you a bit of an insight
into the high level platform.
Predominantly, this is based
around Google's blueprint
for IoT.
You probably see lots of
diagrams in this area.
This is very summarized.
I think the important
aspect in all of this
is this architecture doesn't
necessarily fit every use case.
We have to bring in and use
different components of the GCP
family to address some
of the challenges.
So again, depending
on the speed that you
need to consume the
data, whether you're
looking at these
things in real time,
whether you want to
do things in batch,
you may end up using
different products.
This is just I guess the
common ones that you would
tend to use in such a solution.
From our point of view,
I guess more recently
Cloud IoT Core is something
that we've introduced.
Some of our clients historically
wouldn't have used this.
They would have used
direct connections
or stored the information
centrally, but now
with IoT Core, we can connect
directly to the devices.
And again, as part
of the platform,
we've proven some of
that technology out.
So this is here to--
I guess predominantly, this is
not just for the sensor data.
I think as Mubine
mentioned previously,
there's lots of
other information
you want to bring into the
platform to actually enhance
the prediction models.
And again, different clients
have got different volumes
of information.
So I think back to one
of the other slides.
From a rail perspective,
they have a lot more data
potentially than what
you maybe have on a car,
so obviously the
platform can scale out.
You are able to
process it, you're
able to use the power of the GCP
based on the input data that's
coming into the solution.
I think, again, what we've
touched on previously--
there's lots of talk
about containerization.
And again, coming back to the
algorithms or the solution
causes as Hitachi likes to
call them that we've got,
we can obviously bring
those into the platform.
So again, we don't always
have to use GCP products.
We can introduce our own
technologies and things
that we've invested
in previously
and developed over
a number of years.
So we also can include those.
And again, we'll see some
statistics at the end
where we've actually
done that, and we
can show the benefit
of using the platform.
So we've talked
about the back end.
As you see, lots of components.
From a visualization
perspective,
we've utilized Data
Studio to do what
we would classify as the
standard dashboard capability.
So again, from a maintenance
planner's perspective,
that is where we are surfacing
the consolidated information.
So that's where
the person is then
making those decisions to
support the future maintenance
effort that's required.
But again, Google
AI and Glass, that's
where we're doing the
guided investigation.
And again, all the components
interacting with the GCP
platform, taking data
in, giving data back
after some of the
investigations have happened.
I guess these are some
of the differentiators
that we can call out from GCP.
Obviously from our perspective,
end to end capability,
so we can obviously
collect the data,
process it, analyze it,
and then obviously do
the recommendations
off the back of it.
That's obviously very important.
I think as we mature within the
area of predictive maintenance,
having the ability
and I think probably
some of the announcements
that have come out
from Google this week,
they're continuously
investing in this area
of machine learning
as well as what
Hitachi is doing,
so we can bring our
enhanced capabilities
and use obviously Google's
to progress that
as we go through.
Security is a big thing.
I think Google is best in class
from a security perspective.
A lot of the time when you
configure the platform,
it's just there.
It just does these things.
You don't have to
worry about it.
There's lots of out
of the box capability
that we get with the platform.
And again, obviously we've
talked about different clients
require different needs,
speed, performance,
scalability is obviously
very important for when
we're doing a lot of the
work around the algorithms.
Again, I think we've probably
touched on this previously,
but my background
is BI, and it used
to be you would go and gather
some requirements from an end
user, you'd write a
document, you would then
go away and build it.
And I think in this
day and age, you've
got more parties involved
with the whole process.
Data engineering is very key.
Data is no good if it's
not meaningful and clean.
So there's lots of interaction
with data engineers
and the data scientists,
but obviously
the important people on there
is the business operations,
the subject matter
experts who understand
how these lovely
objects work, and they
need to provide that
input and guidance,
and again I think
we find that is
very critical and key to making
sure that anything you develop
gives you the right outcomes.
So why Hitachi Google?
I think we've touched
upon it previously.
Hitachi has got a heritage
within the industry space.
And I think probably
as a single tag line,
it would probably
be we are using
Google as a platform to bring
our industrial expertise
to the market.
We can see the power
and the benefit
of using the GCP when we are
developing out these solutions.
So yeah, that's a very brief
overview of the technology.
I think as I said,
we're now going
to just go through the
actual demonstration
of the application.
MUBINE DIN: Perfect.
Thanks, Andy.
Now, I'm assuming all
of you have already
come past the booth
and seen the demo,
so this will be the second
time you've seen it.
I'm sure, I'm sure
that's already happened.
So just to give you
an overview of what
we've done with our client.
So obviously, our client
doesn't just have Lego vehicles
Lego isn't the enabler for AI to
be a success and drive insight,
it's just an enabler
for us to demonstrate
some of the pieces we need to.
But essentially, our client
is having a lot of work
that needs to be done from
a maintenance perspective
around two specific use cases,
so AC, so air conditioning,
HVAC in the states, and
also their brake elements.
That's where they're
spending a lot of their time
in terms of maintaining
their fleet of vehicles.
And this fleet of
vehicles is dispersed
across a large
geographic region,
and within their
organization they
have a number of
mobile workforce users,
but they also leverage
a contractor pool
of resources when they need to.
So we started to think end to
end about how we could provide
a solution to help them both
understand where to focus
their attentions and when to
create the right interventions
before assets failed but
also how they could get
the contractor resources
the right information when
they need it visually as well.
Because the last thing you want
as a worker is a lot of paper.
The key thing around
all of this as well
is from a data
management perspective,
a client has access to the data
that comes off the vehicle.
So in Europe, there's
an OBD2 terminal
that sits inside a
vehicle that streams back
lots of information
about that vehicle.
Now, a lot of that
is just noise, right?
You get lots of
information, but you
need to figure out how
that is useful for you.
So I'll just quickly
touch on one of the use
cases we'll talk you through
today around air conditioning.
So our client was
noticing they a lot
of issues in terms
of client feedback
for the vehicles they're
borrowing around AC performance
issues compared to some of the
other maintenance elements,
and a lot of their
maintenance work
was around repairing
or servicing these AC
units across their vehicles.
And each vehicle, obviously,
slightly different unit,
slightly different maintenance
schedule pattern and they
have to follow.
So we worked with our
client to understand
what data points would
be useful to pull back
from the vehicle
around the AC usage,
so looking at the time it took
to get from start temperature
to the desired temperature is
a great starting point in terms
of both cooling and heating.
But then, we looked
at failure information
we could gather from that
client, so their maintenance
records, also the external
data sources that are required
to support the AC use case.
So how do we bring in external
temperature information?
How do we at least
test the value
of putting additional sensors
within their fleet vehicles
so that they can have
a robust data set
to be able to get to a fault
production perspective?
What our client also noticed
and has from an SME experience
perspective is an
understanding that if you
get to these air
conditioning issues in time,
you can actually
remedy them before they
turn into total failure.
So for example, if an asset
has degrading performance
from an AC perspective and
our model is flagging that,
and we know that that
asset was serviced,
let's say, within
the last six months,
it really shouldn't be having
any performance issues.
That is probably
an asset we want
to prioritize
getting to work on,
because those issues
within an AC unit
are usually down to
pressure eroding out
of the system, coolant
leak, those types of pieces.
And they're able
to identify based
on what we created those
elements and those areas
where you could get to
it and repair the hose
or improve whatever issue there
is with it so the whole unit
doesn't fail.
So we'll take you
through that use case.
We have two focuses from
this perspective, the data
dashboard, which Andy will
talk you through shortly
where we're surfacing
all that information,
and we'll talk you
through that, and we also
have the guided AI inspection
piece for that mobile workforce
as well.
ANDY LAMONT: So just looking
from a dashboard perspective,
this is [INAUDIBLE] the
bread and butter BI type
stuff with the means to
surface the information that we
need to take action upon.
So again, from a
dashboard perspective,
what we're doing here is we
are effectively summarizing
the events that have happened.
Now, those events may be
that the system itself
has generated, or
actually in this case
is where we've
executed the models
and it's come up with
these recommendations
of the things that need to
be actioned straight away.
So again, this is
more a maintenance
planning perspective as
opposed to the individual.
Again, we can obviously drill
into the detail of that.
We can go and see the specifics
of where this thing has failed.
So in this case,
air conditioning.
And again, based on
these conditions scores,
this is a score
that we generate.
Again, that's based
on the input factors
for the different
components and models
that we're predicting against.
So again, just a
visual representation
of the information
that we're ultimately
going to go and do some
inspection against.
And that's our
other beautiful car.
We've talked about
HVAC and braking,
but as part of the data
set that we actually had,
the data scientists
were actually
starting to evolve that
if you like and started
to look at things around
drivers' behavior,
because that's
obviously a key aspect
into potential
degradation, especially
things around brakes, where
you have a driver who's
continuously braking and
driving not to the optimum.
Again, something that is
very useful from the fleet
industry's perspective.
It's also used on the
trains, these similar sorts
of things where you want
to try and optimize that.
And again, we've built
out some capability,
and again these
dashboards here are just
showing the aggregated views
and some of the key metrics
that people want to capture
when you're starting
to look at driving behavior.
And again, we can
drill into that detail.
I'll quickly skip through
these, but again, it's
an education thing.
So we can obviously
use that from where
we have to go in and
actually inspect and service
the vehicle, but we can also use
these things from an education
perspective, because obviously
if the same driver is causing
similar sorts of problems,
then we can obviously
take corrective action, which
ultimately will obviously
improve the vehicles that
he's driving or she's driving.
MUBINE DIN: And just to
build on that as well,
so our client's now looking at
the data we're bringing back
from a brakes perspective
and driver score perspective
to say, well, that's
good for maintenance,
but how can we start to surface
some of that information
to that end user, that
driver to let them
know that they're not
driving optimally,
they're accelerating
harshly or braking harshly,
not as a way of telling them
off but as a way of helping them
understand their performance.
We carry health
monitoring applications,
and it's just about
seeing what you're
doing, because you may
be naive to the fact
that you're not
driving efficiently
ANDY LAMONT: Cool, thanks.
MUBINE DIN: Perfect.
So this is the part
where you actually
see the Lego Porsche is
not just here to look nice.
So essentially in
this scenario, we've
created an application for
our client's mobile workforce.
Our client wants that
mobile workforce made up
of contractors to be able to
execute the right activities.
From a maintenance perspective,
there's two or three things
we're doing here, and this
is all about the inspection
workflow.
Within this-- and I'll talk the
examples through as we've got
the video playing
in the background.
But essentially, within
the maintenance world,
you would be surprised but
there are a large number
of times where somebody
goes out to work
on a vehicle or an
asset regardless
of if it's a fleet asset
or any other asset,
and they work on
the wrong vehicle.
I come from a background
in rail slightly
where that was happening.
Everybody feels like they
know where something is.
You get the information from
the database and it tells you
it's in that location.
It's a fixed asset.
You've been there a million
times, you get there,
you see the checklist, you know
what you need to do, you do it,
you mark it as done, you don't
realize there was actually
an identical unit
right next to it,
and you worked on the wrong one.
So we use AR for visual
identification through Google
to help a user
understand that asset.
Now, with vehicles it's easy,
because we have license plates,
we have registration
plates for those vehicles.
With our client, they have three
different types of vehicles,
so we've trained it
against those three vehicle
types but also the
license plate as well
to remove that chance of error.
For the demo purposes
you'll see today,
we've retrained the model, and
we've dummied some of that data
and sanitized it
so you can actually
see the AR image recognition
against the Lego unit itself.
The other thing we do
using the application
is we help the user
understand where
to focus their attention
for this inspection.
So for example, I may be
an AC inspection engineer.
However, I may have not
worked on all the cars
that have ever
existed in the world,
so it's about surfacing the
information for that vehicle,
and it's all about
us then training
the models to
recognize our clients'
vehicles and their assets.
So scalable outside of just
vehicles and fleet assets
but immensely powerful
to helping people
understand what they need to do.
So in this scenario,
we're essentially--
the piece I talked
about, the model
has highlighted an
AC efficiency issue.
This could be due to gas
regulation within the system
or a leak somewhere.
The AC unit was
serviced quite recently,
so it's actually
something that we're
looking for our client to
target and get them out
to complete that inspection.
And we will go ahead and
will complete an inspection
against that unit.
So this is where we're
hoping the magic works
and the video will play.
I will probably
pause it from time
to time just to recap on some
of the things that we're doing.
This is the same overview
of the use casing scenario
that we're working on.
But essentially, user is able
to see the job queue, the work
that they need to go and do.
And obviously, they get
a lot of information
through from our model.
So whatever we hold
in the model will
surface the right
information to them
about what they need to
do, where the asset is,
and then we'll keep it playing.
We essentially
help them navigate
to get to wherever they
need to do the work on.
So for example,
using Google Maps
to get them to the location.
For simple purposes, we
simulate that for this part.
They get to the asset, and they
need to identify the asset.
So the piece I
talked around earlier
around working on the wrong
asset is extremely powerful.
We need to make sure
that we fix things right
first time on the right asset.
So if we hit play, this is where
you'll see the AR element come
in, so the recognition element.
The user holds the mobile or
Glass device across the asset,
and data is pulled
back from our database
to show the pertinent
bits of information
that we want to surface for
that use case and for that user.
For these demo purposes,
we've pulled back the mileage,
we've pulled back the asset
condition score and the focus
area as well.
Now, as we hit
play, the app also
provide information
for that user
so that the user understands
what it is they need to do.
So from an AC
inspection perspective,
there's usually
three things you are
going to look at, the
condenser, the pressure that's
within the system, but
also check the fixtures
and fittings around the hose.
Is there any leakage
happening in that space?
So essentially, the user
is given basic information,
and then they're
guided through this.
So if we click play,
start inspection,
they'll be told,
obviously, where they
need to focus their attention.
They'll scan the asset, so
this is using the camera
to pull back visual information,
check against our model,
and then it pulls back the
information around what
it is they need to do.
So at this point, we've called
out the three inspection areas.
Now, for different
vehicles, different cars,
you will have different
areas to have the hose
or have the condenser
unit, and this
allows them to click in to see
what it is they need to work on
and the steps they need
to carry out as well.
So it's removing the end of
job checklist activities,
and it's focusing
that user on what
they need to be doing when
they need to be doing it.
This can get as
complex as you want
it to be dependent on what
asset you're working on.
So it is really powerful.
And then obviously, the
information is pulled through,
and that passes
through to the database
so that we can have positive
feedback around what
was completed, whether there
was actually a fault in it,
reinforcement with reason
codes so our model can
learn as we go.
So that's the demo from
the AR perspective.
And this is where we're
hoping that it works.
And we can go next.
Again, the value of
why we're doing this.
So the value of why we're
doing this for our client
is to help them reduce
the maintenance burden
and improve efficiency from
a maintenance perspective,
so go and maintain
those assets before they
fail so you don't have to
spend more time and effort when
those assets are out
of commission later on
down the line.
Improve the uptime
for those assets.
So if we can get to a vehicle
and do a small repair as
opposed to having to
do a large replacement,
it's then available to
be used by the parties.
And reducing that capital
cost, so you do not
want to be going out
and repairing AC units
as frequently as
you currently do.
You want to be able to maintain
those units to a higher
level of efficiency so that
they last a lot longer as well.
So the key takeaways, and I know
you're all probably wondering
so what and how much all of
this would factor in from a data
processing perspective.
I'll pass it to Andy there.
ANDY LAMONT: So this is
just an example of why
the platform is really useful.
It's part of one of the air
conditioning investigations
we did some analysis,
and we tried
to extend the data set that we
had to simulate over I think
12 months worth of information.
So you can see there
with those big numbers.
If we were to try and
do this on premise,
we would probably struggle.
So this was a job
that we executed
that obviously spun
up, as you can see,
quite a large volume of compute.
It took about 22 minutes to
run, and it only cost $12.
So when we give this ability
to our data science team,
they're very happy, because
historically they're
mindful of spending
lots of money,
because they know how
much compute power cost.
But they were
actually amazed when
they saw the results of
how much these things cost.
MUBINE DIN: And terms of the
key takeaways from a let's say
learning experience
with our clients,
so Fleet Optimization
is a continual effort.
So it's about understanding
what you want to do,
where you want to
do it, and what
you want to try and improve
from a use case perspective.
So AC breaks with the
start, and our clients
now learning all
the other things
that they might want to
do based on the data we've
been able to pull up
and surface for them.
Data isn't enough.
So the key point is as much
data as you can bring back
isn't enough.
You need to combine that data
with contextual information
but also with that
subject matter
expertise and the ability
to add new sensors
and bring in
additional data points
that you didn't originally
capture because it can benefit
what you're trying to prove.
So for example, with the
use case around brakes,
we brought in the additional
data around driver behavior,
because it's very likely that
if someone is driving badly,
brakes are going to be impacted.
It's not the sole factor for
why that score is calculated,
but it's a combination factor.
Then we bring in things
like terrain, weather,
do those have an effect on how
people are using the vehicle
from a brakes perspective?
And the other key
takeaway from this
is the speed and scale
that you can move out
from Google's perspective.
So you have all of the
access from Edge data
capture to authentication
of new devices
using IoT Core to the
use of ML and Containers
to do the analysis
against that data set
but also robust and
powerful visualization tools
to help provide the
information for that end user
to help them complete their job.
So for example, when we were
talking about the guided AR
investigation application,
we tried it in two ways.
We tried it initially with
just a mobile application
for a user, and then we
tried it with the AR piece.
And side by side, the
client noticed also
that the people who were
using the AR application
were paying more attention
to the work they were doing.
Now, maybe that's because
it's new, novel technology.
But maybe it's that little nudge
that you need to anchor you
in the work that you're doing.
It's so easy to say, well, I've
done this form a million times.
I know what I'm doing.
If you're having to use the
camera and those elements,
it focuses your
mind on the asset
that you're working on as well.
The other part here is all
about technology is important,
but it's technology
plus the business
context that helps you deliver
success and deliver insight.
Your people are your
strongest asset .
This whole process is
all dependent on using
AI advanced analytics through a
change journey with your client
understanding what value
you're looking to unlock,
understanding the
focus areas that you're
looking to prove value in,
and demonstrating that value
to bring other
people into the fold
and keeping those
individuals involved
throughout that process either
through visualization tools,
so soft prototypes that you
can work with them to help
the business understand
what is coming
and adjust what is going to
be delivered in an agile way
so that what they
end up receiving
is actually beneficial
to what they're doing.
I think we've elapsed
towards our time,
and I think we have about five
minutes left for questions.
If any of you are interested
in understanding a bit more
about this, by all means
do you take a picture
and scan that QR code or also
have a look on the Hitachi
Google website, and
you'll be able to access
our information from
the applications
that you saw as well.
And thank you very much
for coming along today.
ANDY LAMONT: Thank you.